mais ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs merci de ce débat et merci
de vous interventions très largement
convergentes entre elles et convergente
aussi avec nos propres lignes même si
chacun s'exprimera à sa façon
vous l'avez tous dit le 16 septembre
dernier mais ça a mis est morte à 22 ans
sous les coups de la police des mœurs
de la République islamique d'Iran il
avait arrêté au prétexte qu'elle aurait
mal porté son voile
[Musique]
une vie détruite et pourquoi pour une
mèche de cheveux dépassant d'un voile
quelques jours plus tard une autre jeune
fille puis tant d'autres étaient
victimes de la même violence lorsque la
répression du régime s'abattit
brutalement sur les manifestants et les
manifestants partout en Iran de sa
caisse la ville natale de Massa mini la
ville sainte de com de machadatéhéran de
Shiraz
tant de vie détruite parce que ces
jeunes femmes osées revendiquer leur
liberté parce qu'elles osaient affirmer
que leur dignité ne valait pas moins
mais autant que celle d'un homme
c'est aujourd'hui un même cri qui
retentit femme vie liberté c'est ce cri
que le régime cherche à étouffer par la
censure et par la violence à ce jour les
ONG ont fait état de plus de 100
victimes sans doute le chiffre est-il
supérieur et de plus de 1000
arrestations de militantes et de
militants d'avocats et d'avocats de
journalistes de citoyens de femmes et
d'hommes unis par la même volonté
d'émancipation
femmes vie liberté c'est ce cri aussi
que la diaspora iranienne Antonne en
Déco de Paris à San Francisco de Londres
à Rome ou à Erbil
dès le 19 septembre la France a condamné
avec la plus grande fermeté les
violences ayant entraîné la mort de
Macha et Minnie et la violence utilisée
contre les manifestants
comme je l'ai rappelé hier à l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons appelé les
autorités iraniennes à respecter le
droit de manifester pacifiquement
respecter le droit au rassemblement et
aussi à respecter l'exercice de leur
métier par les journalistes nous l'avons
fait officiellement et j'ai fait
moi-même auprès de la presse aussitôt
marge de l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies oui si en France à
plusieurs reprises
les autorités iraniennes ont considéré
qu'il s'agissait d'une forme d'ingérence
que de rappeler les principes
fondamentaux des droits de l'homme elles
ont cru bon de le faire savoir à notre
ambassade sur place j'ai donc décidé de
faire convoquer le chargé d'affaires de
l'ambassade d'Iran à Paris car il n'y a
pas en ce moment d'ambassadeurs d'Iran
il a été reçu vendredi dernier au Quai
d'Orsay il lui a été dit clairement ce
que nous pensons des méthodes iraniennes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ceux
qui se jouent dans les routes et errants
et dans les autres villes iraniennes
c'est la liberté il y a d'un côté la
répression une répression brutale que
nous condamnons dans les termes les plus
forts une répression menée contre des
femmes et des hommes qui manifestent
pour le respect de leurs droits et de
leur dignité une répression que nous
avons dénoncé à plusieurs reprises et
que tu continueront à dénoncer je peux
vous rassurer monsieur le sénateur
évidemment sur ce point nous le faisons
au conseil de droits de l'Homme à Genève
nous le faisons dans toutes les ancêtres
internationales et nous le faisons dans
chacun de nos échanges bilatéraux quels
qu'on soit le niveau
rappelons aussi que l'Iran à lui-même
souscrit au principe fondamentaux que
nous défendons ici les principes du
pacte relatif aux droits civils et
politiques des Nations Unies auxquelles
elle a adhéré en 1975 et je précise en
réponse à madame la sénatrice billon que
l'Iran en effet été élu la Commission
des Nations Unies sur les conditions de
la femme c'est la règle majoritaire aura
au sein de chaque groupe géographique
auquel nous n'appartenons pas au
demeurant cet organe est utile car il
produit des documents de référence sur
la situation des droits des femmes dans
les pays et permet donc de mieux savoir
ce qui se passe chez eux
en face les autorités il y a une
aspiration à la liberté et je dis en
face face aux auteurs de la répression
mais je devrais dire partout car cette
aspiration à la liberté nous la voyons
partout s'exprimer les femmes diront
veulent vivre libre et un grand nombre
d'Iraniens les suivent désormais des
villages Kurdes d'Iran au métropole du
Baluchistan de la Caspienne au golf les
femmes diront veulent vivre les femmes
diront volent leurs droits soient
garantis les femmes diront aspirent à ce
que leur égal la dignité soit respectée
le courage des femmes iraniennes force
d'admiration et nous oblige nous
soutenons leurs aspirations et nous
continuerons à les soutenir mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
nous sommes en première ligne pour agir
avec notre partenaires européens notre
réponse doit être à la hauteur de
l'enjeu et en ce sens nous avons lancé
dès la semaine dernière avec nos
partenaires européens les travaux afin
de sanctionner les auteurs de la
répression il s'agira de geler les avoir
et de geler d'interdire donc le droit de
voyager aux individus identifiés comme
responsables des violences il nous
espérons madame la sénatrice Carlotti
que ce soit fait d'ici 8 à 10 jours nous
sommes 27 dois-je vous le rappeler
madame la sénatrice Vogel permettez-moi
aussi de préciser que les négociations
sur le retour aux jpcoe ce sont conclus
par la présentation d'un texte que
l'Iran n'a pas pour leur accepté en
d'autres termes elle ne se déroule donc
pas quoi que la conclusion d'un accord
aurait un fort intérêt pour empêcher
l'Iran d'accéder au seuil nucléaire ce
qui sera de loin préférable chacun en
conviendra
nous resterons totalement mobilisés aux
côtés des Iraniens et des Iraniens qui
se battent pour leurs droits à la
dignité car vous le savez hélas les
violations des droits de l'homme en Iran
n'ont pas attendu les événements récents
nous continuerons d'aplay l'Iran à
mettre fin aux discriminations et à
toutes les formes de violence envers les
femmes et les filles à interdire les
mariages précoces et à permettre l'accès
des iraniennes à leurs droits en matière
de celles de santé sexuelle et
reproductive quand il s'agit pas que de
l'obligation de porter le voile
l'oppression que subissent les femmes
iraniennes et brutales
inscrites dans les lois de la République
islamique autant que profondément
enracinés dans les mœurs du régime
aucune société nous le savons ne peut se
développer sereinement si elle n'assure
pas l'égalité des droits l'égalité entre
femmes et hommes l'égalité entre femmes
et hommes qui ont une condition du
développement et qui est même le gage
d'une société libre un élément
fondamental de la justice indispensable
à nos vies
ce combat essentiel n'est donc pas notre
seul combat parce qu'une société injuste
avec les femmes et tout simplement une
société injuste pour tous nous
continuerons à dénoncer les arrestations
arbitraires des cinéastes des militants
des droits de l'Homme les femmes et des
hommes engagés pour la défense de la
liberté d'expression d'étudiants de
journalisme nous continuerons à dénoncer
les exécutions auxquelles il est procédé
y compris les exécutions de mineurs
et nous le faisons et nous le ferons
parce que c'est notre responsabilité
nous le faisons et nous le ferons parce
que nous avons le droit moral et
politique de défendre les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres oui mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs nous
disons tous ensemble la femme et
l'élégale de l'homme en Iran comme
ailleurs je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]